(atmospheric music)
- Jetliners are basically flying homes.
It's a sealed pressure canister.
It's incredibly strong.
It will last practically forever.
I'm Bruce Campbell, and you're inside
the cockpit area of my 727 home.
I can appreciate that
some folks might feel
a bit isolated or that it
might simply strike them
as an unusual living environment.
But for me, it's always
felt completely natural.
(playful music)
The entry is via the aft airstairs,
which are retractable and are retracted
whenever I leave for an extended time.
The aft area of the aircraft
now is my living space.
My very primitive shower is located there.
The two natural aft lavatories
are both functional.
Sleeping quarters are there, in the form
of a simple futon sofa.
And a bench, where I spend
lots of time embellishing
elements of the aircraft.
Jetliners retire at the
rate of about three per day.
For the most part, I think we shred them.
And then we spin around 180 degrees
and make a home, after
having just shredded
an aerospace class home sized structure.
If you were an
extraterrestrial looking down
on this behavior, you'd
wonder whether this species
has all its marbles in place or not.
(evocative classical music)
People have asked me
whether it crashed here,
and I simply restored the wreck.
That's an odd thing to hear.
It's completely impractical.
Next time you're in a jetliner,
close your eyes for a moment, in your mind,
remove all the seats
and all the other people
and then open your eyes with that vision
and consider the expanse
of the living room.
It's a good environment, it really is.
(birds chirping)